jeunesse
[Musique]
ce
dès les premières minutes du gala de
l'adisq un artiste il nous était en
vedette ce qui est bénéfique car
originaire de oicha mak mani-utenam à
participer aux grands de venir au
collectif d'ouverture un acné
mais c'est l'artiste multidisciplinaire
oggi cry1ac need qui a remporté le félix
d'artistes autochtones de l'année entre
tradition et modernité sa musique est à
mille lieux des clichés folkloriques
associé à la musique autochtone à
de nouvelles sonorités
les nouvelles voies autochtones sont
multiples et touchent à tous les styles
comme le rappeur q zéro phyto qui
composent du hip hop engagé les hip hop
ça vient du bronx c'est bien de niort
puis ça vient d'eux des places gâteau
des places marginalisés ça fait que dans
les communautés autochtones on vit
beaucoup de la même chose
des artistes émergents talentueux comme
qu'amène qui s'inscrit fièrement dans la
tradition des musiciens qui ont pavé la
voie moi c'est un peu ça aussi mon
inspiration c'est elisapie kim qui m'a
fait qui m'a fait de jeu peut faire
tout comme km matthew est originaire de
malioténam une véritable pépinière de
talents depuis le plus longtemps que
c'est
toutes mes amis savent jouer un peu de
guitare on gratte et on se rassemble et
ont déjà mensonge puis je te poses pas
le guitariste j'étais pas le lead guitar
hero autour de la table c'est plus les
drummers de table
mais
je peux pas nier la guitare
l'eau bnl musique nomade fondée par
manon barbeau accompagne des artistes
autochtones dans leur développement
chante le public curieux en ce moment
puis j'espère juste que ça va durer qui
se sera pas juste une mode ou un moment
je pense que le défi qu'on n'entend
quelle société en tant qu'industrie
c'est de mettre les assises pour que ce
soit ce qui est une pérennité à ceux des
artistes bourrés talents qui ont des
choses à dire et qui sont prêts à être
connu et à briller comme il le mérite
ici nabi alexandre chartier radio canada
montréal
[Musique]